[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro on est avec vous on est
en direct c'est figaro live et on attend
ce soir vos points de vue on attend
également vos réponses à la question
pensez-vous qu'un troisième confinement
serait respectée c'est dans c'est pas
pensez vous qu'un troisième continent
sera respecté ça c'est déjà une question
qui a été déjà posée mais ses pensées
vous êtes vous favorable fermeture des
écoles pour d'or le mois de février
il y avait déjà 70 mille votants sur le
site du figaro on posera la question à
sophie de menthon ce soir présidente du
mouvement patronal ethic et chefs
d'entreprise bonsoir ce infi et on
posera la question à richard bouhet
bonsoir richard dunne année et ben merci
vous et on en sait ça finit à la fin de
la semaine
oui alors on a jusqu'au 31 janvier
accord bien donc nous n'y sommes pas
encore et donc on est heureux de pouvoir
souhaiter les meilleurs voeux à richard
bouygues expert à la fondation jean
jaurès et adjointe ps à la mairie du 12e
arrondissement de paris l'autre débat
que je vous propose d'avoir ces satini
c'est autour de cette initiative de la
ministre déléguée à l'égalité et la
diversité
l'instauration d'un index de la
diversité pour les entreprises qui le
souhaitent
alors est ce un pas vers l'avènement des
statistiques ethniques et de la
discrimination positive
on attend vos points de vue mais d'abord
le couvre-feu ne suffit pas à faire
reculer le virus nous sommes sur un
plateau montant nous voulons éviter une
épidémie dans l'épidémie tout laisse à
penser qu'elle sera une réalité si nous
ne faisons rien voici donc ce qu'a
déclaré en début d'après midi vous avez
pu le suivre en direct peut-être sur
figaro live
sûrement même olivier ferrand le
ministre de la santé alors que faire
comme disait quelqu'un qui n'est pas une
référence pour ce film entente
c'est-à-dire lénine
on a l'impression que le gouvernement
tous les cas se pose encore la question
et
béchard briques nous précise que pour
lui non plus lénine n'est pas une
référence
on a l'impression tous les cas que le
gouvernement se pose la question lénine
comme le suggère cette déclaration de
gabriel attal ce matin chez nos
confrères de france inter je disais
qu'on était dans une situation
particulière avec ce variant dit
britannique qui se développe et que
évidemment ils tous les scénarios sont
sur la table rien n'est exclu
on arrive vous l'avais dit dans une
période de vacances de février sur un
mois selon les trois zones
il ya les vacances de février et donc il
est évidemment possible de réfléchir à
allonger les vacances d'un côté ou de
l'autre mais encore une fois notre
objectif
ça reste évidemment que les enfants
puissent continuer à apprendre alors que
les enfants puissent continuer à
apprendre
allonger les vacances d'un côté ou de
l'autre on imagine que le débat va être
âpre surtout après avoir entendu jean
michel blanquer
au même moment mais cette fois ci sur le
plateau d'un autre média du service
public france 2 france 2 dans l'émission
des 4 vérités présenté par caroline ans
dans la situation grave
à l'échelle mondiale actuelle de
déscolarisation de grand nombre
d'enfants du fait de l'épidémie ce qui
va à des conséquences graves dans là
pour l'avenir de monde la france se
détache positivement donc nous devons
être fiers collectivement de ce qui se
passe doit évidemment être vigilant sur
le plan sanitaire
à ce stade encore une fois les
contaminations n'explose pas en milieu
scolaire et donc nous devons évidemment
maintenir les écoles ouvertes autant que
nous pouvons
autant que nous pouvons on va voir donc
dans les prochains jours sophie êtes
vous favorable à la fermeture des écoles
pendant le mois de février je rappelle
que c'est la question qu'on pose sur le
site du figaro je crois que j'aimerais
pas être à la place du président de la
république parce que il est devant
vraiment un choix impossible
c'est vraiment un choix impossible on a
toutes les prévisions si l'économie
s'arrête à nouveau trois semaines parce
que confinement ça veut dire commerces
fermés ça veut dire salariés qui
viennent encore beaucoup moins ça veut
dire on est reparti dans le délire
absolu de l'essentiel non essentiel
parce qu'il faut bien se nourrir ou quoi
faire d'autre et c'est donc c
c'est très difficile d'un autre côté moi
je dis a priori je dirais qu'il faut
éviter ça d'un autre côté à l'hôpital
j'ai eu des échos aujourd'hui même de
déjà encore quatre personnes dans un
couloir sans lit et 30% des personnes
testées à l'hôpital du kremlin bicêtre
qui au le nouveau variant angles et 30%
et tous les services transformer en lit
qu'ovide donc ça fait peur d'entendre ça
quand on voit la situation de
l'angleterre on ne peut s'empêcher de se
dire que quand on sait que le variant
est forcément dominant sur le vieux
vieux coronavirus si je puis dire
donc on se dit que l'hypothèse dacca
tout comme l'angleterre est probable
alors je crois qu'il faudrait changer un
peu de méthode confinement est ce qu'on
fait en qu'est ce qu'on nous je crois
qu'il faudrait prendre des décisions
beaucoup plus logique plein de bon sens
ne pas hésiter à faire des différences
parce qu'ils veulent mettre tout le
monde au même niveau non alors ça veut
dire certaines parties de la population
non je pense que d'abord il faut
continuer à essayer de mettre les
enfants en classe parce qu'ils risquent
rien plus tôt on à faire plus tu trouves
la con mais plutôt pour la vo
l'ouverture des écoles non maintenant
c'est très difficile en données d'hier
chier on va faire si on va faire ça je
sais pour je compte je crois qu'il faut
absolument laisser les enfants à l'école
ils vont encore bien les parents
tiennent le coup si vous lui mettez en
plus vous oubliez les parents et les
enfants qui doivent s'instruire mais les
parents devaient devenir fous et ils
vont pas aller bosser dans les boîtes et
en plus si on prolonge mois lors des
vacances de trois semaines ça veut dire
quoi vacances ils vont pas travailler
les enfants les parents vont faire quoi
les garder le télétravail c'est plus du
télétravail c'est du gardiennage
donc c'est très compliqué on peut pas
rester sur ces espèces de position qui
ont été édictées et qui ne veut plus
rien dire
richard je pense aussi que c'est une
situation et une décision qui va être
difficile à prendre
qui est compliqué et pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord je pense qu'il ya une
forme de confusion mais qui est à la
fois normal et peut être regrettable
d'un autre côté une confusion pourquoi
parce que ce que les épidémiologistes
savez au début de la crise est ce qu'ils
savent aujourd'hui
sur le rôle des enfants l'impact sur les
enfants et le rôle de propagation ou pas
de l'enfant dans un autre milieu que
celui du milieu scolaire notamment de la
famille accomplie a complètement évolué
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on a des
études très contradictoires on n'a pas
une étude qui dit de manière très forte
et qui fait consensus au tas au sein de
la communauté scientifique
on a eu une confusion sur ce qu'on
retire de l'ensemble des études qui ont
été faites aux états unis en europe pour
la plupart la dernière de publier dans
hollande 7 6 a été fait à one et qui a
montré quand même un nouveau rôle dans
la propagation par les enfants des virus
notamment dans le milieu familial et qui
a un peu jeté les bases d'un doute
nouveau sur cette propagation c'est
antoine flahault c'est quand même un des
épidémiologistes les plus reconnus à
l'université de genève
mirsky qui évoque le fait qu'on a
probablement sous-estimé le rôle des
enfants dans la propagation la diffusion
déconner de l'épidémie pas sur le côté
contagiosité ce qu'il n'ya pas en fait
un peu dans les services de pédiatrie
aux urgences ont une explosion des cas
mais dans le rôle de la propagation et
on s'interroge sur l'âge notamment je
vous rappelle que la différence entre la
propagation et la contagieuse valable
alors la contagiosité c'est je suis
contagieux et je suis en capacité de
développer les symptômes qui vont avec
sauf si je suis assez symptomatique est
donc de développer une forme de maladie
chez les enfants il ya quand même valu
un consensus de la communauté
scientifique pour dire que globalement
les enfants ne développent pas des
formes graves qui sont souvent
asymptomatique quand qu'il développe
c'est souvent des choses qui sont plus
fallait dire ce que c'est que des
enfants dont ils n'ont pas les symptômes
qui ne sont pas malades en fait mais
peuvent propager porte
c'est ça le soir vous rentrez à la
maison et vous avez un environnement qui
est des adultes et vous pouvez tout à
fait être en capacité de propager encore
une fois il s'agit pas à le vouloir ou
pas de vouloir c'est juste seule cette
partie là qui a peut-être selon encore
une fois les scientifiques je ne suis
pas mais quand je lis ce qu'ils
appellent la littérature scientifique
terre en fait ce pourquoi je dis ça
parce que la question vous êtes vous
êtes
justement adjoint au maire du 2e
arrondissement paris et vous avez donc
la question des écoles et en particulier
des écoles primaires gérer dans ce cadre
là est ce que vous êtes favorable vous
d'un point de vue
du point de vue qui est le vôtre à ce
que l'on allonge les vacances scolaires
ou bien est-ce que vous êtes favorable à
ce que dit jean michel blanquer
c'est à dire autant que j'ai autant
faire possible garder lé calendrier
actuel et sachant que les deux
propositions sont parentes agonise un
bon moi je pense qu'il faut maintenir
l'école ouverte parce qu'on a vu au
premier confinement que finalement
fermer les écoles enjoindrait aussi des
effets très pervers et très délétère qui
était notamment la montée des inégalités
scolaires puisque en fait vous avez
énormément d'enfants qui ne sont pas en
situation de suivre à distance parce
qu'ils n'ont pas le matériel parce
qu'ils n'ont pas les parents pour les
aider et c'est donc que vous aviez une
aggravation des inégalités scolaires
liés au confinement que d'autre part ce
n'était pas forcément pour les parents
une solution qui était non plus
judicieuse puisque il fallait garder les
enfants et que donc ça voulait dire se
priver aussi pour certains d'aller au
travail d'aller travailler et que à un
moment donné les parents ont eux aussi
envie
excusez moi de dire comme ça de
reprendre et de reprendre une activité
professionnelle et d'autres types
d'activités donc moi je pense qu'il faut
le plus possible éviter ces effets
pervers et donc maintenir les écoles
ouvertes mais même moment donné on va on
va avec une situation qui est vraiment
dramatique et je pense que là il faut se
poser la question est ce à dire que en
dernier recours oui fermont mais
pourquoi fermer d'ailleurs quand ça va
très mal
on peut affirmer pas fermé alors c'est
compliqué d'abord il faut faire une
énorme différence qu est ce qu un enfant
jusqu'à quel âge parce que ceux qui
craquent et qui commence à disséminer
les virus c'est le les jeunes à partir
de 15 ans alors là cela on peut plus les
tenir on les laisse sortir les parents
là à vous et on n'arrive plus du tout à
l'équipe est la nôtre blême les publics
français dans la tranche d 09 en cas
beaucoup explosé je vous rappelle
qu'elle est en janvier à peu près à 10
ans taux d'incidence qui était très haut
beaucoup plus haut que celui de la
population française qui aujourd'hui
environ environ 2,7
donc en fait c'était aussi sur cette
tranche d'âge alors ça va aussi avec un
nombre de tests plus importants qui ont
été effectués mais néanmoins ça a
beaucoup surpris ce taux d'incidence
importante sur cette tranche d'âge des 0
9 ans que jusqu'à présent on pensait
complètement épargné par louis echelard
des notes
attention c'est d'un autre côté et
contaminent alors il faut aussi replacer
il contamine
s'ils continuent leurs parents c'est le
taux d'incidence sur les cas détectés
lesquels est élevé mais il faut savoir
aussi que quand il ya ça dans les
familles heureusement les enfants des
parents jeunes par définition est que la
moyenne d'âge quand même des gens qui
sont qui meurent de cette maladie qui
sont malades gravement et qui sont à
l'hôpital c'est 80 non encore donc il ya
aussi une on arrive à plus très bien
comprendre
d'ailleurs je ne reviendrai pas
là-dessus mais je trouve que c'est une
telle aberration d'avoir commencé à
vacciner les ehpad en premier que c'est
quelque chose qui ne me dépasse
complètement dans la stratégie de lutte
contre ce virus
donc alors il ya aussi autre chose parce
qu'on parle des vacances
allonger les vacances mais ça va être
beaucoup plus dire quand on va vous
expliquer parce que c'est ça la crète
la crainte c'est que les gens partent en
vacances c'est faire circuler le virus
de région à région et on parte en
bretagne à la montagne etc
c'est ça la terreur où tout le monde les
flux de populations c'est ce qui les
inquiète tous donc peut-être moins la
circulation puisque contrairement à la
première vague
aujourd'hui on a une carte de france où
on voit que le le taux de seuil d alerte
est partout partout des pâtisseries en
revanche en pas identiques mais en tout
cas il est largement dépassée partout
peut-être c'était un peu moins vrai dans
l'ouest de la france mais ça commence à
l'être en revanche là où il ya une vraie
question c'est sur les capacités
hospitalières dans les différentes
régions et que en gros aujourd'hui on
avait déjà des régions qui nous disent
que ça c'est une question que c'est une
autre question que vous soulevez je
voudrais avant de l'aborder salué les
internautes qui nous suivent le duc de
blangy ce magnifique ceux de nîmes
astrid j'ai eu également daniel 8,6 et
s'il bat et babineau bien entendu qu'ils
nous suivent et que je salue on va vous
donner la parole ce serait de la folie
une destruction du moral des enfants une
prison pour leurs parents et un mois
blanc pour l'économie nous
donc le duc de blangy ce les écoles non
mais oui pour fermer les lycées nous dit
astrid est ce que vous pouvez expliquer
pourquoi vous êtes savoir la fermeture
des lycées où je rappelle qu'on a
quasiment supprimés ce qui restait de
l'épreuve du bac
en tous les cas puisque maintenance et
le contrôle continu total j'ai horreur
perdre une année d'instruction ne rend
pas malade il y à des étudiantes n'ont
pas commencé à gagner leur vie à 20 ans
certains se cherche encore perdre un an
n'est pas si grave que ça en plus ils ne
sont pas sûrs de trouver du travail
après leurs études sur ce que dis-je et
or il y as d'un autre côté la situation
il ya la contestation également qui
monte dans le monde et dans le monde
étudiant sur la fermeture des
universités est ce que vous êtes
d'accord exclusif cet internaute ou bien
est ce que vous vous dites quand on voit
la situation dans l'inertie terre et des
contestations qui montrent le malaise
étudiants est ce que c'est bien
raisonnable en plus maintenant encore de
se dire on va fermer ou pas les et moi
je pense qu'on peut pas fermer alors les
écoles les étudiants c'est très très
grave
il faut les laisser retourner enfin que
ces cds des jeunes qui pensent à se
suicider il ya un malaise psychique est
vraiment grave prendre ça au sérieux
et alors est ce qu a pas d'autre moyen
de faire une préservation beaucoup plus
important de la distanciation être
beaucoup plus rigoureux être plus sévère
et on prend des mesures
par exemple le coût du couvre-feu à 6h
et table sur 2 ça n'a pas marché tout le
monde est dans la rue à la même heure
ça ne suffit pas du tout ça me sera
servi à rien ça a servi à la basse et le
moral de tout le monde
c'était une mauvaise idée charbon il
n'est pas d'accord elle ou non je pense
que c'est pas une mesure qui est en fait
qui montre ses freins si on regarde les
courbes
il y a un effet on sait pas exactement
si c'est une corrélation par contre est
ce que en gros la courbe a un peu baissé
parce qu'il ya eu couvre-feu aussi c'est
d'autre chose par contre ce qu'on sait
c'est la c zéro
ce qu'on sait qu'en plus c'est qu'au
bout de deux semaines elle a commencé à
remonter c'est à dire qu'en fait j'ai
sur l'effet inverse donc en gros oui
c'est une mesure qui n'est pas probante
c'est bien voici sur les sur les
étudiants moi je pense qu'effectivement
il faut réinventer un système où il fait
si avoir du présentiel en 2000 euros
pour qu'il puisse y avoir un vent
comment lancer un système
alors je me rend triste et les moments
où il faut inventer et on peut très bien
avoir des td qui au lieu d'être à 30 ou
40 on les fait en 2 x 15 en deux fois
dix jours ne sait rien il ya des salles
qui le permettent mais dire qu'on prive
complètement les étudiants décident
d'une anniversaire je trouve que c'est
difficile c'est quelque chose qui est
aujourd'hui très corrélé avec
l'augmentation de tous les troubles ont
matière mais si chic en matière médicale
en matière d'isolement enfin il ya quand
même beaucoup aujourd'hui des enquêtes
qui ont été faites et qui montre le
trouble des étudiants je crois qu'il
faut qu'on revienne sur un système où on
invente voilà des salles en 2000 groupe
des amphis qui sont plus les mêmes pas
utilisé pour les mêmes choses que ça
j'ai cessé les cours à distance d'une
deuxième année de fac
c'était hallucinant elle avait donc son
écran il y avait le prof qui a pas
réussi à régler donc on voyait que le
haut du visage du prof qui était tout en
haut dans un petit carré on voyait des
carrés noirs parce que les enfants ont
pas du tout se mettra envie de se mettre
en vidéo parce qu'il faut autre chose
pendant ce temps là il a parlé le prof
tout seul c'était en mai mais un
cauchemar je veux dire ça ne pourrait
pas fonctionner la chose c'est enfin par
rapport à ce débat c'est après des
questions de cohérence
c'est à dire comment on peut dire que
globalement un td en
en fac serait pas possible mais par
contre que les transports c'est possible
comment plaisir que le supermarché c'est
plié
la salle de cinéma adressé à un moment
donné j'ai souvent eu l'impression qu'il
ya quelque chose qui soit n'est pas dit
c'est très maladroit parce que ça
alimente des faits que nous séduit
complot soit ça donne l'impression qu'on
ne comprend pas le deux poids deux
mesures alors j'ai une question j'ai
aucun intérêt dans la sphère parce que
je prends pas que généralement de
vacances en février à ce moment là mais
je salue car tout les internautes qui
habitent les régions de montagne et j'ai
une pensée pour eux dans ces conditions
pourquoi les stations de sports d'hiver
ne sont pas ouvertes et parce qu'il n'y
a pas plus de raisons
sur une piste de ski d'attraper le corps
d'un virus
alors je vais y aller en février j'ai
été j'ai même installé dans une mairie
salon pour sophie de menthon et alors là
la réalité c'est que si dans les alpes
centrales
la réalité c'est que l'hôpital de
sallanches et était déjà saturé en co
lead et que alors moi je veux bien on se
fait soit disant une fracture et qu'on
pourrait imaginer un hôpital dans la
station qui résoudrait ces problèmes là
vous ne pouvez pas il ya plein
d'accident vous avez des ambiances hélas
enfin le suisse par deux essais 3 4 par
jour on génère les hôpitaux aussi vous
avez les bennes alors il faut se
trimballer à 2 dans une benne dont
ensuite s'accorder
quand vous dites les bmc télécabine
comme ça vous pouvez mettre un masque
dans une télécabine
enfin quand vous êtes la télécabine vous
avez commencé pendant les vacances
scolaires un train un train un train de
banlieue pendant le de toute façon je
pense en heure de pointe et l'embolie d
urgence par conseiller
alors là l'embolie des gens sont cons
est bien d'accord et c'est ce que dit
patrick peloux ici souvent c'est que
c'est quand même la situation dans les
hôpitaux
le problème de l'hôpital
et on pas de problème de circulation du
virus est le président dans tous les
autres pays je vous signale faire tomber
est ce que est ce qu'il faut pas sophie
je pose la question à libéral que vous
êtes ce qu'il faut pas augmenter les
moyens des hôpitaux pour pouvoir
attendre il faut non seulement les
augmenter mais pourquoi des hôpitaux du
privé de tout le monde on a on a refusé
je répéterai jamais assez
au début de l'épidémie toute l'aide des
cliniques qui disait on a des lits de
réanimation ils sont vite venez
l'hôpital dit hannon et le gouvernement
disait dont tu as hallucinant donc il
faut revoir ça et on sait très bien que
nous avons un personnel administratif
dans les hôpitaux qui est le double de
l'allemagne alors que e.on du personnel
pour soigner on sait qu'on a un problème
là mais ce que je ne comprends pas parce
que bon on va pas refaire le monde
sauf que c'est le moment je ne comprends
pas pourquoi c'est pas le café du
commerce
on échange ici des points de vue le
numéro 20 oui mais vous savez je ne
méprise pas dit où le café du coton non
plus en plus tout à fait sûr la
expliquez moi pourquoi quand on a vu que
nous hôpitaux ne suffisait pas qu'il
fallait de l'hydre et à y en a eu
combien créer moi j'aurais mis tout le
fric là dessus je veux dire que ça fait
longtemps maintenant ça fait presque un
an qu on ait confié qu'on a ses
problèmes de l'icm ans quand on a mis un
nombre de lyme encore très faible on n'a
pas augmenté notre dans une entreprise
quand vous avez un afflux de quoi que ce
soit de clientèle de demande
immédiatement l'oms
alors oui et oui mais avec une limite
qui est que à un moment donné on ne peut
pas non plus se satisfaire d'avoir
cinquante cinq mille personnes en
réanimation
donc on pourrait pas créer 55 me lis pas
si on n'est pas souhaitable qu'on a il a
su parce que quand on va en réanimation
on va pas en chambre d'hôtel c'est un
moment qui est très difficile c'est un
moment dont vous sortez parfois avec des
séquelles et d'après ce que nous ferons
de plaisir donc les soins je me demande
s'il faudrait pas non plus être con mais
un système qui soit un peu différent à
négliger les soins comme du so fine jeu
il ya une recherche qui c'est qui a été
beaucoup dans la réa et
soigner les gens on est beaucoup moins
au real parce qu'on a fait des progrès
quand même énormément être prises a
permis qu'on apprenne à probablement
mieux prendre en charge mieux soigner
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs assez inexistant
on hésite aujourd'hui des personnes en
réanimation parce qu'on a appris à ne
pas les envoyer en réanimation et à
mieux les prendre en charge sur la
partie kovy des coraux la vision moi ma
proposition est la suivante c'est
pourquoi finalement notre système d'
alerte
il est quand c'est un peu tard c'est à
dire quand les réanimations les entrées
c'est à dire qu'est ce qu'on est en
vente comme système d' alerte qui nous
permettrait en amont c'est à dire avant
que les hôpitaux soient saturés avant
que les réanimations soit s'attirer
d'avoir les le système d' alerte qui
nous permet de dire là il faut qu'on
prenne des mesures avant qu'il ne soit
trop tard et souvent nous c'est quand il
est tard comprend les mesures je vous
propose de continuer ce débat dans une
autre fois également en tous les cas on
va continuer à en parler
la question qui était posée c'est si
vous êtes favorable à une fermeture des
écoles pendant le mois de février
alors ce qui est très intéressant c'est
que sur twitter vous répondez oui dans
une large majorité alors que sur le site
du figaro c'est exactement l'inversé et
c'est même on aborde là on atteint les
60% de nom
à sète à la réponse à cette question
vous pouvez continuer à voter en
particulier sur le site du figaro ça
vous a peut être échappé mais ça date
d'il ya une quinzaine de jours l'idée a
été lancée par quelqu'un peu connu c'est
elisabeth murdoch et au ministre délégué
pour l'égalité et la diversité a succédé
à ce poste à marlène schiappa et elle
propose aux entreprises qui le
souhaitent de mettre en place un index
pour la diversité en clair faire l'état
des lieux des minorités sexuelles
ethniques et proposer je cite des
actions correctrices la suite est
expliquée par l'intéressé c'était le 14
janvier dernier
nous sommes donc aujourd'hui à un
tournant nous vivons un moment de prise
de conscience mais il ne peut y avoir de
diversité sans politique de promotion de
la diversité et c'est l'un des coeurs de
ma mission
il n'y a pas de politique de promotion
de la diversité sans acteurs engagés
sans vous sans l'investissement des
associations des entreprises des
collectivités toutes les politiques
publiques que nous pourrions mettre en
oeuvre serait vaine
sophie de menthon vous qui vous êtes
battu justement pour la cause des femmes
en entreprise ça doit vous alors je me
suis battu pour la cause des femmes dans
l'entreprise parce que je dirais je
pense que les femmes doivent
effectivement être beaucoup plus
présente dans les entreprises c'est pas
une cause et
et alors d'abord je pense qu'une chose
c'est que on a autre chose à faire en ce
moment dans les entreprises parce que
c'est bien de dire qu'il faut une
diversité je le conçois tout à fait
c'est vraiment pas le moment surtout que
quand elle explique on va faire ça sans
contrainte ça veut dire qu'on a quand
même des contraintes et que fair and
adac ça veut dire qu'on va quand même de
comptes et ça veut dire également alors
là moi je suis un peu étonné on n'était
pas supposé faire de de calcul on n'est
pas supposé savoir exactement ce qu'il
en est d'un comptage de diversité au
sein des entreprises entre la loi mais
là tout d'un coup maintenant il va
falloir compter et puis il faut de tout
c'est à dire que il faut évidemment des
handicapés c'est dans les normales
accent que vous avez bien le staff
technique finalement ça glisse je suis
pas coach m'a fait cet interdit en
france alors ça vient de tomber
en revanche les statistiques ethniques
pourquoi pas mais de toute façon je vous
dire en ce moment les ce qu'on va
recruter qui auront la chance d'être
recruté on va recruter les meilleurs
et l'autre jour j'ai quand même eu le
cas dans une grande entreprise pas si
les grandes entreprises sont tout à fait
prêtes à faire des quotas ils sont
beaucoup plus une pme prend les gens qui
leur sont utiles vite fait il a l'air
génial et franchement et il ya un
candidat qui est arrivé et on lui a dit
qu'on vous a convoqué vous avez un cv
génial mais je suis désolé et nous
manquons à des statistiques à respecter
est là et on peut pas vous prendre alors
il a dit mais comment ben non parce
qu'on a des stats ici de tous les côtés
y compris dans la sexualité dans il a
dit est ce que voulait le deviennent
mots pour pour avoir le poste ce que je
peux faire quelque chose au lieu dit non
monsieur mais on doit respecter
donc quand on commence à se fixer des
objectifs comme ça ça me gêne énormément
alors ça ne veut pas dire qu'il ne faut
pas intégrer le plus possible je pense
que les boîtes le comprennent que c'est
pas tellement les que les patrons ne
comprennent c'est une chose mais ils
sont toujours suspects mais il y a une
véritable la véritable le poids des
salariés dans l'entreprise ce sont les
salariés qui veulent cette diversité
parce que ça correspond effectivement un
mouvement ici qui disent ah bah oui non
mais c'est bien il faut ils véhiculent
ce type de désir cela dit
je pense que c'est pas le moment et que
c'est quand même une contrainte de plus
richard aulas temps votre point de vue
sur cette question
moi j'avais un peu une question de l'élu
de gauche que vous êtes
c'est que quand j'entends les aet moreno
proposé ça j'ai un peu l'impression que
c'est la république il à cindy soyez
noter qu'on assassine et fort qu'on
assassine peut-être pas à disons que
dans un monde idéal où la république
serait idéal c'est question ne se
poserait pas mais elle se pose parce que
de fait ce n'est pas propre à
l'entreprise mais dans la vie politique
la représentation des femmes dans la vie
politique
elle a souvent été un homme il ya
souvent des barrières pour que les
femmes puissent se trouver une place
dans un monde qui était très marquée par
l'empreinte par l'empreinte des hommes
et il a fallu pour ce réalisateur je
pense pas margaret thatcher mais vous
pouvez vous me citer en exemple et elle
est quasiment rappelez-moi apparel et
theresa may les derniers premiers
ministres en angleterre il avait en gros
quelques caractéristiques bon président
de la république en france mais premier
ministre femme c'est à dire non mais
aussi qu'est-ce que alors dans le temps
et dans l'absolu
- vous auriez al assad dans ces
conditions si je me suis vous auriez pu
voter pour marine le pen à la dernière
élection présidentielle
non parce que l'or en fait une
caricature que vous faites mais bon on
va dire ben non c'est leur vocation de
paris-nord et de comment vous savez bien
que dire qu'on veut promouvoir la
diversité veut pas dire que la diversité
doit effacer tout le reste on pouvait
pas pris c'est pourquoi parce que quand
je reprends mon mot ma démonstration en
politique si vous n'avez j'aurais
souhaité mois ne pas avoir les quotas en
politique
j'aurais vraiment souhaité ne pas les
avoir simplement vous savez comment ça
se passe dans les partis politiques dans
les partis politiques qui a eu très peu
de place aux amandes fait mais
exactement ce qui mousse qu'ils menacent
qu'ils montraient bien une posture je
prends ce milieu politique pour vous
montrer que je suis aussi patriote et
avec eux le milieu dont je suis pour
partie est partie seulement issue donc
je sais très bien que la place des
femmes a été compliqué que souvent leur
donnait des circonscriptions gagnables
mais ça faisait statistiquement on l'a
proposé à une femme simplement elles
avaient moins de chances de gagner
pourquoi parce que sociologiquement la
circonscription était plutôt de l'autre
tendance pour aussi des femmes
incompétentes 1 mais pourquoi pas tous à
exister et il a fallu
moment donné bon là je vois que sur la
loi qui a été votée je crois en 2000 il
ya cinq ans il me semble et dont on fait
aujourd'hui qui a permis quand même dans
les entreprises du cac 40 et dans les
grandes entreprises
le mouvement a commencé mais uniquement
sur certains postes on aimerait que tout
ça non plus ne cache pas toute la
question qui est un peu plus bas sur
l'égalité salariale les qualités
professionnelles qui sont là des vraies
questions et qui ne sont pas que celle
de la représentation et qui doivent se
poser donc moi je ma position est la
suivante c'est que je regrette qu'on en
arrive là
je regrette que à la république n'ait
pas pu à un moment donné mieux permettre
l'expression des diversités mais je lui
aussi à la télévision enfin je vais pas
faire un mois un constat du plateau que
nous représentons aujourd'hui c'est
beaucoup trop faible en termes des
champions mais la question justement là
je posais la question inverse c'est que
justement est ce que ces mesures n'ont
pas l'effet inverse de ce contre quoi
elles veulent lutter pour parler simple
le racisme est ce que justement elle
réintroduit ce pas la notion d'ethnicité
jeu si on suit il y a la valse en
passant franchi un cap ce tiers que il
ya le cap du cv anonyme du testing etc
qui vise à lutter contre la
discrimination à l'embauché parce que il
ya peut-être découle des problèmes de
couleur de peau de sexe de d'orientation
sexuelle encore que sur un cv anonyme je
vois pas comment on peut dessiner
orientation sexuelle mais tombe est bon
et et que l'on sent primum femmes ont
soit on l'a on peut mais là on va plus
loin c'est à dire qu'il faut qu'ils
aient on oblige à ce qu' il y ait des
gens de
de telles dettes à l'origine de telles
orientations comme ça c'est ça qui est
ce que c'est pas l' inverse de ce contre
quoi c'était ses luttes et alors c'est
un des risques très clairement c'est un
des risques
vous avez deux risques vous avez l'idée
de créer un gadget consorts j'ai un
index et que ça fasse rien du tout cet
index en plus il faut voir tout ce qu'on
aura dedans on a bien vu que dans les
entreprises du cac 40 où il y avait eu
aujourd'hui on est à je crois à 40% dans
les grandes dans les grands organes de
direction de représentation des femmes
mais tout le monde dit qu'il ya un autre
problème c'est qu'en gros elles toutes
les personnes qui sont dans ces organes
viennent à peu près de grandes écoles en
matière de formation que l'âge on a une
pyramide des âges qui est très limité on
a très peu de jeunes qui rentrent dans
ses conseils donc lundi il doit croiser
plein de choses y aura probablement un
indice qui va croiser peut-être une
statistique ethnique même si je suis
aussi étonné parce que je ne sais pas
comment on va l'introduire regard de la
loi mais imagine interdit par exemple
et après c'est on fait quoi de ça on
fait quoi de ça parce qu'une fois qu'on
a sorti l'index et si c'est simplement
d'exposer mon index et il est bon donc
je des actions correctrices d'elisabeth
alors les actions correctrices moi je
vais bien avait d'abord elles ne seront
pas que dans l'entreprise et parce que
les actions correctrices elles ont
besoin d'être un peu plus large que
d'être simplement en entreprise qui
serait là seulement voilà donc je
regarderai traitement attention aux
attention à ce que d'abord oui on a
quand même un problème de représentation
mais dense et palika l'entreprise
l'entreprise est un des lieux dans
lequel ça se passe il ya des inégalités
professionnelles on le sait sur les
salaires entre les hommes et les femmes
on sait qu'il ya des difficultés alors
de moins en moins mais ça existe de
moins en moins parce que ça troll est là
dessus et puis dont on fêtera demain il
faut que les femmes marie c'est très
compliqué mais ça m'est arrivé dans mon
entreprise et elle était arrivée au
bouton vous savez je gagne moi que alors
que j'aurais pu jeter bas dit le
effectivement elle a été recrutée moins
cher de l a augmenté à compétence égale
à compétence égale à égal oui enfin
alors il ya un autre biais qui est
terrible pour les salaires aussi dans
leurs propos de compétences égales vous
n'avez pas le droit vous avez par
exemple 2
collaboratrice les poches du deux
assistantes parce que voilà il y en a
une qui est génial qui buzz comme une
folle qui a des résultats formidables
j'ai voulu l'augmenter ou donner une
prime d arrache ses pointes et me dit
mais c'est interdit faut augmenter les
deux autres tu commences à augmenter les
doses optionnelles qui est certainement
de santé fragile puisqu'elle avait un
très gros absentéisme et qu'en plus elle
travaillait beaucoup moins que ça
n'intéressait pas enfin il ya on voit la
différence entre un bon et un mauvais eh
bien vous ne pouvez pas augmenter ni
donner une prime à quelqu'un qui a le
même poste que quelqu'un d'autre
donc ça c'est de l'égalitarisme qui n'a
pas de sens et donc il faut pas en
rajouter
allez on donne aux internautes nathan
770 qui estime que ces statistiques sur
le préambule à la discrimination
positive
alexandre nous dit je n'ai pas très bien
compris l'index sert juste à répertorier
ou à fixer des quotas
pour l'instant c'est juste à répertorier
ces trucs là c'est un index méfier mais
oui c'est un peu là c'est ce qu'on vient
de dire c'est soit c'est quelque chose
qui va être un gadget soit c'est quelque
chose qui va être aignan qui va être
contraignant est en tout cas qu'est-ce
qu'on fait progresser dans un cas comme
dans l'autre en réalité parce qu'on peut
aussi rester en buts sur les deux plans
c'est raté à la fois des mesures
intéressantes de promotion et à la fois
il ya une autre question qui était posée
par patrick je vous laisse mais s'il
faudrait déjà que cette diversité soit
adaptée aux besoins de l'entreprise
est ce qu'on demande à un peu trop aux
entreprises notamment autour de cette
question de la responsabilité sociale
des entreprises et et environnemental et
environs développé avec vos alliés dont
sur la rs ça va c'est pas une invention
écologistes donc pour répondre à patrick
est ce que justement oui c'est la
question est ce que c'est
ses opposants est-ce que encore une fois
on revient à cette idée est ce que c'est
aux entreprises de corriger les
célébrités ou
ou bien celle là d'état par exemple
enfin ça dépend parce que là on vient de
faim encore une fois tout dépendre d'eux
il n'y a pas de discrimination mais
attends je pars à tant d or et enfin
faut voir de quoi on parle parce que en
fait une partie de la loi visait plutôt
les comités de direction et leur
représentation et notamment la place des
femmes lancée que vous c'était la loi
d'il ya cinq ans là aujourd'hui on va
plus loin nous parle d'un l'index qui ne
concerne pas uniquement les comités de
direction qui pourrait être aussi sur
une photographie globale de l'entreprise
et donc aussi de ses salariés de ses
cadres etc
donc il ya quelque chose qui est un peu
plus globale est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on
en demande pas beaucoup à l'entreprise
peut-être qu'on en demande beaucoup à
l'entreprise parce qu'on part d'une part
de loin et parce que je pense que les
petites choses on les a pas encore
complètement corrigé
je suis désolé mais d'égalité
professionnelle n'est pas encore là so
fine alors il faut vraiment difficile si
la grande tendance en france on parle
des entreprises c'est pas du tout pareil
vous avez la boîte de quatre personnes
je vous dirais les ailes lui demander de
faire ça elle aura pas besoin d'un index
le fait que dieu d'accord à partir d'une
boîte de 100 personnes qui sont des
petites boîtes aussi avec cette personne
l'index mais attention parce que là il
ya discrimination quatre personnes
feront trajet mais d'effort particulier
quand on a une toute petite boîte pour
aller chercher quid handicapées s'est
bien passé a été que nous sommes
beaucoup battus pour qu'ils intègrent
les entreprises mais là aussi il y avait
des boîtes d'intérim et ont préféré
payer plutôt que d'avoir un handicapé
par sa mère la boîte d'intérim
parce qu'on a tellement de contraintes
en revanche je pense à éthique on à
boiron par exemple laboratoires boiron
ils ont une politique incroyable de
diversité on à lvmh le méchant riches et
qui a une politique farnham par exemple
pour être très clair la sncf d'aller
trop loin dans la diversité par exemple
aujourd'hui alors même payé ville de
paris parce qu'elle a trop d'adjointe
enfin les postes de direction ouest et
est un autre débat de paix auquel je
vous renvoie et voulait pas qu'on en
fait trop mais dans certains
mairie du 12e arrondissement mont
charles richard on al andalous nos côtes
a été respecté a rappelé avoir tout dit
pas d'herbe
arrêtons de copier de l'universel que le
modèle américain on voit où ils en sont
avec une profonde déception des tensions
raciales embauches se fait à la
compétence la couleur de peau n'a rien à
voir là dedans c'est ridicule est-ce que
c'est justement parce alors que chose
qui là aussi peut être un instrument qui
aille contre l'intégration
quand même il faut le dire il ya eu
quand même je me demande si c'est pas
encore le cas donc on n'en est pas au
stade des états unis ou dans les cv il
est noir vous le mettez de côté les gars
d'en face à la discrimination à
l'embauché
anecdote mon premier boulot je
travaillais sur une boîte qui faisait du
recrutement par téléphone et nous avions
de la part des boîtes qui recrutait des
indications sur les profils recherchés
je peux vous dire qu'il y avait la
discrimination ethnique je les
boulangers le nom d un moment là c'est
pourquoi il y aura toujours
descrimination d'abord recruté c'est une
discrimination
1 vous apprenez à vous animez 4 donc
c'est une description des critères qui
sont ainsi les critères qui sont
intéressants et je pense que c'est même
d'ailleurs assez insultant pour des gens
qui ont des couleurs de peau différentes
et ses objets du pouce et je pense que
quand ils sont bons maintenant surtout
aujourd'hui il se pointe dans une boîte
on a pas d'hésitation à ce que disait
michèle alliot-marie disait je suis
arrivé président du rpr par mon talent
pas parce que j'étais une femme et que
fait-on cet index nous nous demande
stéphane danser la concession seules les
compétences comptent nous dilutive munch
se se focaliser sur les arras et tout
faire pour raviver le racisme dit romain
et ironie pour stopper le racisme il
faut arrêter de mettre en place des
mesures qui se base uniquement sur la
couleur de peau de quelqu'un si tu nous
dis c'est le retour du racisme
différencier les gens en fonction de
leur couleur de peau ou d'une autre les
attentions c'est pas un index de stats
ethniques c'est de diversité y aura pas
que des meilleurs
aujourd'hui on les entend aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui à d'autres discriminations
dans l'entreprise exactement et
notamment la place aussi deux tranches
d'âge dans leurs rôles dans les
représentations dans les recrutements
et c'est pas rien aussi fin vous pouvez
en avoir aussi pour des pères de famille
qu'on n'en voit pas dans des avec tori
combler un certain nombre d'enfants et
qu'on n'en voit pas dans certains pays
étrangers parce que ça pourrait coûter
cher aussi aux exploits tri en terme
d'exploit tri nations c'est un autre
c'est un autre débat mais je ne vous
laissez pas idiot avec l'école fermée
avec l'école fait amer je ne fais pas
c'est une c'est une vraie question c'est
est c'était à c'était un élément je vous
somme était je vous dis pas que si
c'était un témoin quart temps je connais
moins que vous les experts
merci je retiens merci beaucoup
en tous les cas de nous avoir suivis par
dont on a explosé les temps mais vous
avez été très nombreux en tout cas à
réagir ce soir je vous appelle la
question composé sur twitter établi à un
index de la diversité dans les
entreprises est il une bonne idée
question donc posé et vous êtes une
large majorité de non à cette question
qui n'est pas comme le dirait et comme
le rappellerai avec justesse guillaume
roquette un sondage ça tombe bien vous
ne retrouverez guillaume roquette demain
ici même heure même endroit a très vite
su
[Musique]